[Música]
qué tal bienvenidos a su programa canadá
en las américas el castor cibernético de
este viernes 31 de agosto de su fin de
semana también gracias por acompañarnos
a todos nuestros oyentes y ciber
seguidores en radio canadá internacional
desde nuestros estudios aquí en montreal
aquí en el estudio se encuentran mis dos
colegas argentinos que quiero tanto
leonardo
laborda como están como muy bien y los
controles técnicos estallan tasan sobre
una vieja conocida de radio canadá
internacional también esta semana al
menos lo mismo que una conocida vieja no
no
desde una vieja que no es muy joven como
nosotros o más quizás más joven que
nosotros aquí como cada semana tenemos
claro temas como los que nos han
conmovido preocupado interesado durante
la semana quiero que en canadá se estado
hablando muchísimo del tratado de libre
comercio las últimas exactamente ha sido
casi el tema excluyente y en el fondo
hablamos de marihuana marihuana en el
tema
en los temas que estuvimos tratando y
que estuvimos escuchando en los medios
de comunicación y nosotros hicimos
reportajes entrevistas artículos de
noticias toda clase de cosas que tenemos
que trabajar toda la semana pero antes
de irnos a esos temas que nos han
interesado conmovido preocupado etcétera
esta semana el menú es bastante
melodioso y rítmico barba
yo no me gusta me gustan comenzamos con
los ritmos vamos con los ritmos
[Música]
podemos escuchar de fondo lo que vemos
allí en el vídeo es al al músico al gran
músico conocido antonio rivas que está
de paso por montreal está ahí en ese
caso con otros músicos pero se está
presentando de todo el marco del
festival internacional del acordeón hoy
acá un monte al del acordeón en la
ciudad de montaña aquí en canadá en
quebec está el trío antonio rivas y los
tenemos también por skype a los tres a
los tres miembros de este trío antonio
rivas presentándose en ese festival
internacional del acordeón los salida
los saludamos a todos ellos antonio
rivas daniel ochoa jairo gómez como
están bienvenidos a radio canadá
internacional a canadá en las américas
cómo les va
fue muy bien y espero producir yendo
gobernador que bueno desde cuándo están
ahí en mamá
llegamos
9 el miércoles después de 24 25 de
transporte si es menor
que bueno y ayer fue la primera
presentación del trío dentro del marco
de este festival como decía cómo estuvo
el ambiente señora antonio rivas
bueno yo sería
los objetivos de hablar de cobertura
ambiente pero me pareció que hubo una
comunión entre el público y nuestra
música
si les gustó me imagino que la gente que
va ahí de por si le encanta el acordeón
y descubrí el acordeón colombiano pues
es una obligación casi para quien nada
para quien gusta del acordeón
yo digo
y bastante del público muy interesante
porque es un público que le gusta mucho
escuchar escuchar lo que está viendo
todo esto entonces es para nosotros un
reto
sobre todo esta música es bastante
festiva que dará de moverse de bailar y
bueno estar en una sala con la gente
sentada de poco tensionante porque
entonces la gente se puso a bailar con
ustedes
d
al final vamos a ver si en los
siguientes conciertos porque va a haber
otros conciertos entonces de ustedes
otros dos conciertos me parece
conciertos más en el festival
internacional del acordeón de montaña
que en francés se llama el café mundial
del acordeón yo iría para preguntarle
ahora al al
antonio rivas como tal usted comenzó a
solo a los 15 años a tocar el acordeón
cómo fue eso que lo motivó a comenzar
con este instrumento
y bueno pero
eso fue bastante casual porque yo tocaba
en la banca
y tenían un colega que también tocaba la
voluntad y un día voy a visitar con un
acordeón diatónico y me quedé
sorprendido pero como él
y vas encontrando la ruta y así comencé
con una armónica aquí y el corcito darle
poco a poquito
porque no es bueno
no le iba a decir que en realidad si yo
veo un acordeón una y una armónica no
simplemente no me parece que se parezcan
mucho
[Risas]
la mano derecha del acordeón por ejemplo
y una hilera corresponde a
acercamiento a la idea de la armónica
ciencia ronca
de acuerdo a lo que hace con la mano
izquierda con la mano izquierda qué es
lo que hace es
dos cosas de la rodilla y la rítmica
[Música]
y el bajo
dado
y con la derecha son las notas
y además el pequeño botoncito aquí que
permite al de abrir huella y haced
entrar en el aire
y mucho tiempo
[Risas]
entonces cuando logró encontrarle todo
el sabor al instrumento fue cuando
empezó a sentirse más cómodo me imagino
aparecen los vídeos que he visto de
usted no parecen para nada incómodos con
el instrumento al contrario daniel ochoa
usted viene desde francia acompañando a
antonio rivas porque tanto ni usted vive
en montpellier en francia y danielle
usted lo acompaña desde allá que le que
le pareció el público quebequense con
respecto al público francés es más o
menos del mismo tipo no
el público francés también publicó un
incidente muy buen escuchar como energía
y de verdad
haciendo la comparación con dos públicos
aquí el público canadiense es mucho más
exigente en el sentido de saber escuchar
cada nota saber apreciar cada cada
melodía en todo de eso el público no
quiere decir que el público francés es
normal y lo hacen pero el público
francés me como más apto a escuchar eso
pero lo sentí y voy a reaccionar me
estoy sintiendo voy a disfrutarlo voy a
bailar y bailar más tal vez los
franceses
[Risas]
porque bueno
ese concierto
y una pregunta el instrumento que usted
toca cómo se llama esto se llama
cabalgata lo que pasa que aquí veo
instrumento que un poco modernizado con
jackie en acrílico poner todo eso pero
en general tradicional tradicionalmente
es un instrumento que es que fabricado
de madera era con piel de animal de
archivo de archivo de acuerdo con lo
salado tanto escucharlo para tener
sonido más más agudo más fuerte entonces
en cambio más lo que han cambiado los
materiales justamente para que el sonido
sea más nítido digamos más todos muchos
cambios
un elemento de madera y estos son muchos
las sales mucho más graves
hay muchas cosas y me han dicho que
también toca otro instrumento que se
llama la guacharaca ja
y dijo que
suena con el contacto y como está y no
sé cómo están deslizando con el desliz
[Risas]
nosotros constantemente también porque
está acompañando de eso es un
instrumento de lamento parte de otras
percusiones se siente oficialista que ha
aprendido un poco de muchos de muchos
profesores que están en el mundo que me
ha enseñado que todo había sido aprender
y por otro lado usted jairo gómez usted
vive aquí en quebec en canadá es bajista
profesional me parece haberlo visto con
varios otros grupos no solamente latinos
sino de otros de jazz y en otros eventos
porque como como el como le parece esta
experiencia con antonio rivas y con
danger
daniel ochoa
[Música]
nuestra música colombiana le ha dado
mucha oportunidad de tocar continuamente
esa música de la constancia de nuestro
bien alegre y es un estilo que me gusta
bastante
entonces me siento muy contento y muy
feliz de la oportunidad de tocar con
antonio en su música que la conocí a
través de días es importante para ti y
tuve la fortuna de
qué bueno
les pediría ahora voy a preguntar por a
casi perdido
no los vemos moverse los escuchamos
a lo mejor ellos no nos escuchan vamos a
llamar de nuevo le recordamos a nuestros
oyentes que estamos en comunicación por
skype y claro siempre puede haber
cuestiones técnicas problemas de
comunicación sabemos que skype es un
medio de comunicación que hoy en día
utiliza mucha gente pero la velocidad no
siempre acompaña y es obvio que a veces
genera problemas tanto de audio como de
imagen congelada qué es lo que pasaba
recién sobre todo tiene que ver con la
velocidad de la red digamos si uno tiene
la conexión inalámbrica es un poquito
más endeble la comunicación si uno tiene
un conectado un cable que es nuestro
casa y en nuestro caso funciona bien
pero bueno uno no puede pedir a los
demás que tengan exactamente lo que no
tiene este lado poco tiempo más el
internet está a la puerta siempre del
próximo año o dentro de dos años tiene
que ver un cambio hacia la próxima
generación de servidores y de iu del
sistema de comunicación en sí mismo así
que supongo yo que eso era mucho más
posible mucho más eficaz en todo caso
y comunicaciones de este tipo que son
cada vez más frecuentes y que hoy por
hoy nos ofrecen posibilidades de
contacto que hasta hace muy pocos años
atrás eran impensados y las tenemos de
nuevo ahí al tri va antonio rivas que
como decíamos están participando dentro
del marco del festival internacional del
acordeón o el café
montreal del acordeón en la ciudad de
montaña aquí en quebec canadá nos
escuchan
ahora
pero ya vamos a ver para cepillar vamos
a escuchar dígame están por ahí muy bien
ahora les voy a pedir para allá para
concluir está esta comunicación con
ustedes que nos tocan algunas piezas y
te esperemos que no se nos caiga la
rueda vamos a tenerle confianza a la red
para que nos toquen un fondo hace un
extracto no muy largo de alguna de las
piezas que estuvieron presentando lo que
van a presentar en los conciertos hay en
mamani
muy bien perfecto muchas gracias
estamos al tanto entonces si me va a
gustar estoy segura
pero
[Música]
[Risas]
i
[Música]
[Risas]
o no
tú
[Risas]
[Música]
sí no
[Risas]
[Música]
no no
[Aplausos]
o no
[Música]
muchas gracias escucha perfecto a se
escucho perfecto el trio antonio rivas
es un trío que me parece que se formó
para esta ocasión no es cierto porque
veo que son de diferentes lugares
entonces se han de haber reunido para
esta ocasión
y la música
no está para nada parece que han tocado
siempre juntos aparte en realidad tienen
la sangre colombiana junta que eso los
agrupa
de una manera muy especial eso sí ya de
por sí lo tan en la sangre
en el bautizo era que había que hacerlo
porque a veces las las iniciaciones
pueden ser dudas
no les agradecemos muchísimo que hayan
aceptado participar con nosotros en esta
aventura porque ya nos dan ganas de
irnos para mamani pero no queríamos
perder la oportunidad de hablar con
ustedes antes de que antes de que se
fueran de quebec de canadá así que
muchas gracias
ya vamos vamos a organizar a bailar
mamani entonces muchísimas gracias
antonio rivas daniel ochoa jairo gómez
muchas gracias el trío antonio rivas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
ciao vamos ahora una pequeña pausa y
entonces ya regresamos a hablar de
nuestros temas de la semana
[Música]
soy hitler aprende capel y es nuevo
pronto switch una provincia al este de
canadá y los invito a escuchar canadá en
las américas café el programa dominical
de radio canadá internacional en la ya
no es dominical
también el domingo pero parte dominical
parte sabatina
el viernes 6
que les pareció el trío antonio arriba
muy a mi edad pues yo yo no escucho
música centroamericana de sentarme
escuchar no escucho pero cuando le
escucho vengan a bailar el ritmo
cumbianchero no nace no sé si tiene que
ver con nosotros o elena sea todo el
mundo igual pero cuando uno lo escuchó
empieza como si viendo el más como se
movía el cuando tocaba el acordeón con
un movimiento súper acompasado y
atención como el acordeón ha sabido
sobrevivir en generaciones y
generaciones de otros instrumentos y
sobre todo la llegada de las nuevas
tecnologías es un instrumento que no es
fácil de ejecutar por más que el parece
demostrar lo contrario y que se
encuentra presente en más de un estilo
musical en américa latina en diversos
países se lo aplica o se utiliza mejor
dicho de distinta manera y a mí me
sorprende que hoy en día se lo aplique y
me sorprende más todavía que haya un
festival dedicado del mundial del
acordeón lo que quiere decir que muchos
países me imagino que en casi todos los
países del mundo hay algún estilo
musical en el que se utiliza el acorde
amor aquí y la música caliente la música
country de acá de canadá tiene todo ese
ritmo acordeonista claro exacto igual
aunque digamos que sea la base diferente
del acordeón hace una unificación ahí en
ese tipo de música si es un sonido muy
particular
tenemos un salud y otras cosas
[Música]
de cristal está escuchando viéndonos en
directo y nos preguntaba si los
invitados tocaban vallenato s abrazos a
paloma louis y leonardo no más de tres
minutos esa música de la costa del
caribe colombiana dice así que vayan que
barranquillera saludos para los músicos
de parte de otro colombiano pablo
barrios parte del hombre de la mano
grande
hubiera sido muy ha podido ser parte de
este trío en la parte de bailar del
cuarteto colombiano
que mueve las caderas como ninguno
veíamos también a antonio rivas que
hubiera querido estar de pie yo creo
para bailar no en toda su salida de su
silla para arriba
bienvenida tipo axl rose estado que el
que la que no sé que la calidad del
sonido fuera mayor verdad pero no les
queríamos perder no nos olvidemos
atraparlo una vez que vimos la
comunicación
exactamente entonces ustedes esta semana
estuvieron observando la actualidad
haciendo reportajes y todo esto algún
tema que haya llamado observarla para
trabajarlas y trabajarlas otras cosas
bueno como decíamos al principio de
emisión uno de los temas que ha
sobresalido durante esta semana casi
excluyente ha sido el tratado de libre
comercio de américa del norte
ya que el reciente anuncio del
presidente de eeuu donald trump de haber
llegado a un acuerdo con méxico causó
primero sorpresa luego sosobra y hoy
cuando faltan muy pocas horas para que
venza el plazo por lo que se ha llamado
el plazo político que es algo extraño en
este en este tema generalmente no hay
plazos políticos es generalmente los
presidentes los jefes de estado se
mantienen un poco al margen de la
cuestión de la negociación como tal si
se llama plazo político porque en leh
hay que distinguir entre lo que por un
lado impulsa precisamente la política
dentro de esta renegociación
y por otro lado está digamos el brazo
legal del tratado o de los tratados
internacionales de libre comercio que es
mucho más complejo que demanda mucho más
tiempo y que no se puede deshacer de la
noche de la mañana y eso es tal vez es
lo que el señor trump en su en su
jolgorio aviso no ha tomado mucho en
cuenta si igual él cree que lo deshizo
completamente si dijo que él el tlcan
estaría muriendo
murió pero tocado está por no decir
hundido pero tierra todavía falta para
que el tratado quede desactivado hay que
dar numerosos pasos uno de ellos no
menor que es pasar una votación en el
congreso de los eeuu
y además tomemos en cuenta que las
conversaciones todavía se están llevando
a cabo en este mismo instante que
nosotros estamos aquí sentados hacer
haciendo este programa las
administraciones exteriores christiane
phyton están llevando a cabo gestiones
en washington ella lidera las
negociaciones canadienses
hasta ahora no ha trascendido demasiado
de lo que vienen siendo estas últimas
conversaciones iniciadas el jueves por
la tarde que no han dormido mucho y
sería de esperar en todo caso porque se
hubiesen dormido mucho tomando en cuenta
que este tema se está quemando es que
eso ya sería más preocupante si lo que
es cierto es que desde el principio
méxico en todo caso el presidente
mexicano cuando se cuando se terminó la
negociación con mexico entre eeuu y
méxico
el presidente dijo bueno falta canadá y
lo mencionó en varias ocasiones en la
conversación que tuvo con donald trump
si inmediatamente después de que terminó
la negociación entre méxico y eeuu y
desde entonces ha habido varias
intervenciones por parte de méxico y de
canadá diciendo bueno muy bien que se
pusieron de acuerdo pero todavía queda
la siguiente la eurocup aparte de la
confusión surge precisamente de eso si
primero se trata el tratado de libre
comercio para américa del norte se trata
de un convenio tripartito en el que
participan méxico canadá y eeuu
al comienzo de esta semana el presidente
estadounidense anunció un acuerdo
bipartito en el que involucra a su país
y a méxico y entonces la gente los
analistas el público en general comenzó
a preguntarse en nosotros también cómo
es esto y dónde está y la confusión
viene por el hecho de que por un lado se
anuncia como un acuerdo bipartito pero
por el otro lado se dice y en parte o es
buena parte de la verdad en todo caso de
lo que se trató de esa negociación
bipartita de avanzar en temas que
efectivamente hacen a la relación
bipartita entre méxico y eeuu sin que
eso significa ser necesariamente una
voluntad cerrada de abandonar el tratado
entre las tres partes claro que luego en
su euforia el señor trump a su modo como
ya es habitual en el confusión siguió
entonces la con la pregunta que quedó
flotando y dónde está canadá exacto
porque además dijo a mí me gustaría que
este tratado se llama da el tratado
norteamericano entre méxico y canadá
entre méxico y eeuu
o algo así un título en el que se
excluía canadá entonces todo el mundo se
quedó pero a pesar de su maniobra
digamos o de su accionar para no
calificarlo de manera tan peyorativa
tampoco yo he llegado a la conclusión de
que nada lo hace al azar crea que el
presidente de eeuu sea quien fuera vamos
a poner los puntos sobre las íes en este
caso estamos hablando del actual
mandatario que es nuevo el trampero sea
quien sea que sea mandatario de eeuu o
de cualquier otro país no es tonto podrá
cometer errores podrá impulsar políticas
que son más o menos populares hasta está
calculado pero no llega a la presidencia
de ninguna nación
siendo un inocente y
careciendo de las cualidades que hay que
carell que hay que tener mejor dicho
para ejercer ese tipo de funciones y
justamente el tema del tratado de libre
comercio de américa del norte fue el
tema que estuviste uno de los temas que
nos quieres destacar esta semana lewis
conversas te con alejandro villamar
calderón del viernes
eres integrante de un colectivo mexicano
que se denomina mexico mejor sin tlc se
va a decir sin tratados de libre
comercio y hago hincapié en la
pluralidad de la expresión o en el
carácter plural de la expresión en todo
caso mejor dicho porque precisamente en
una entrevista anterior que le había
hecho a villamar calderón él decía que
las distintas organizaciones sectoriales
y de defensa de los derechos los
trabajadores que existen en méxico en su
mayoría propician una salida de los
tratados de libre comercio porque porque
dicen que éstos en última instancia no
favorecen nunca a los intereses de los
trabajadores y mucho menos en un país
que en términos potenciales se
encontraría en condiciones de
inferioridad de respecto a los eeuu ya
que las condiciones de trabajo
particularmente de los tres perfiles que
efectivamente entonces su colectivo
propicia la o propiciaba en algún
momento por lo menos la salida de los
tratados de libre comercio yo por eso me
pregunten
la entrevista a la que está ahora
vigente en nuestro sitio en internet si
el anuncio del presidente de un acuerdo
bilateral había modificado su posición
de alguna manera y él dijo que no y que
de hecho lo que anuncio trump es en su
opinión un acto mediático que tiene por
objetivo solamente presionar a canadá
para que acceda
o para que conceda mejor dicho
posiciones respecto a los reclamos de
eeuu y solución de eliminar tarifas para
ciertos productos estadounidenses y en
algunos sectores más complicados como
por ejemplo es el tema automotriz que es
uno de los sectores más complicados
dentro del tratado de comercio o de
libre comercio sabemos que trump ha
basado parte de su política en defender
a algunos sectores automotrices y esto
es tan delicado que uno puede llegar a
pensar por ejemplo bueno el señor trump
está defendiendo la industria automotriz
la industria automotriz no está nada
contenta con las actitudes del
presidente de shows y nada sindicatos
particularmente exacto y además porque
en la actividad automotriz la gran
ganancia está precisamente el mercado
internacional no está en el mercado
interno entonces para no confundirse en
ese plano no es la industria motriz la
que va a apoyar los dichos del
presidente estadounidense y ahí hay un
otro punto referido a esto y no quito
mucho mucho más tiempo sobre este tema
es hay un
un capítulo de ese acuerdo bipartito que
se habría acordado entre estados unidos
y méxico que es el d
asegurar que al menos una parte de la
producción automotriz sea realizada por
operarios que cobren un piso de 16
dólares es decir que no ganen menos de
16 dólares ahora por hora efectivamente
entonces uno dice bueno fantástico esto
va a significar que el salario de los
operarios mexicanos más sube y si no
necesidad diariamente no necesariamente
al contrario eso puede ser un arma de
doble filo muy bien pensada por trump
que como bien dice
leonardo gimeno no es tonto para
repatriar parte de la actividad
industrial que escapó de territorio
estadounidense cuando las condiciones de
producción no la favorecían dentro de su
profesión ahora en eso coincide con los
sindicatos porque los sindicatos dijeron
mientras méxico siga ofreciendo salarios
tan bajos así o sea un costo de
producción tan bajo para la industria
automotriz los trabajadores canadienses
y los estadounidenses también por
consecuencia no podrán competir con esa
industria que ya está instalada en
méxico entonces en ese sentido coinciden
un poco aunque no completamente con los
sindicalistas el tema es tan complejos
de lo que villamar calderón dice es eso
no va a afectar absolutamente nada si
tienen que aumentar el salario de los
trabajadores mexicanos lo van a hacer
porque las ganancias de la industria
automotriz no es no y no están solamente
en
mezquindad salarios ya están puestas en
otros lados ya están aseguradas por
otras vías entonces eso es lo que menos
interesa entonces esta entrevista con
alejandro villamar analista y activista
del movimiento méxico mejor sin tlc es
la pueden encontrar en nuestro sitio
internet y leonardo gimeno nos presenta
un nuevo concepto a la moda
jane que según especialistas a mí me
pareció muy interesante esto va a
revolucionar varios aspectos tediosos de
la vida cotidiana quiero saber lavar la
vajilla pero por ejemplo y es uno de los
ejemplos que no está ahí pero que decían
los artículos que de ley para armar este
este artículo uno va a viajar al
exterior y ti tiene un seguro por la
llegada tarde del avión así el avión
tarda más de dos horas en despegar desde
el horario en realidad hasta que
realmente despega
uno cobra ese seguro normalmente cuando
uno tiene ese tipo de seguros tiene que
ir a discutir a la empresa tiene que
mandar papeles que hay que mandar montón
de reclamos tienen que tener formularios
esto con el block change sería
automáticamente
porque en realidad es un listo nace con
las cripto monedas con el bitcoin y
después apareció aéreos y ahora el
mercado está lleno de equipo monedas
pero la que realmente llamó la atención
y nos pegó todos en la cara
así fue el bitcoin y es una manera muy
especial de guardar información y de que
esa información sea una de las grandes
cosas que pasa en este momento es que
todo se puede hackear bueno es que según
dicen los que saben en el block change
es dificilísimo bajas de hackear
entonces es una manera de poner un
montón de información bajo una
estructura que sería inviolable y que
sería que actúa mucho más rápido que los
métodos que nosotros conocemos por
ejemplo en el caso de la de las
cuestiones bancarias yo voy al banco
tengo que hacer una operación hay
alguien en el banco tiene verificar
tiene que llamar a otro banco hacen otra
verificación hay computadoras en el
medio pero yo tomo
un tiempo bastante largo en que eso se
efectivicen y que digamos sea legalmente
correcto en este caso con el block
change se podría hacer casi
automáticamente porque no hay
intermediarios y porque uno puede hasta
firmar contratos hacer un montón de
cosas que cotidianamente no tienen a
maltraer y que con esta nueva tecnología
podría llevar a un montón de cosas que
se están la agencia de seguros ya están
con esta intención de meterse hacia el
blog chen y obviamente el sistema
financiero mundial lo está pensando
seriamente y no hablan de bitcoin hablan
de la estructura de la tecnología que
podría usarse en otros niveles que no
son necesariamente el equipo de manera
podremos incluir en él tres tareas
nefastas como son lavar los platos
cocinar y sacar la pasión al perdón
es hermoso claro es pura feliz a la
gente además terminar de cocinar le das
de comer a tu mujer y es feliz
y bueno yo esta semana les presento un
reportaje a partir de una entrevista con
karim el as al del instituto de
investigación canadiense y también think
tank the conference board of canada que
concluyó que para mantener los niveles a
los altos niveles y los altos estándares
de niveles de vida del nivel de vida en
canadá y lograr un crecimiento económico
positivo y canadá necesita continuar
aumentando sus niveles de inmigración
entonces se necesitan más inmigrantes
mejor
enmarcados y mejor acompañados pero en
todos los sectores de la economía dice
tanto en los sectores que son más
específicos y más puntuales en términos
de tecnología como en otros sectores
menos especializados se necesitan
inmigrantes y canadá tiene que seguir
recibiendo los entonces y les hacen una
prueba que me pareció simpática o
interesante en todo caso en el que
evalúan calculan qué pasaría si canadá
no tuviera que no recibir inmigrantes de
tuviera una política cero inmigración
pues el país se iría abajo rápidamente
porque claro a la población está
envejeciendo
hay muchas mucha gente que está yendo a
la jubilación entonces están jubilándose
y la economía no se mantendría en pie y
hay un cambio relacionado a esto
hice una noticia la semana pasada con
respecto a la ley en china que permitía
un solo hijo que me a partir de 2016
permiten dos y ahora le serán abriendo
se anula y la gente no quiere tener
hijos es un mal de la
es muy distinto de tomarla porque no nos
volvimos que supera largamente a los mil
millones de habitantes y yo creo que en
el puesto 15 si no me equivoco
ejerciendo un amplio sector de la
juventud china se está yendo a vivir al
exterior y además hay un desplazamiento
interno en china como ocurre en muchas
otras partes del mundo de gente que se
está yendo las zonas rurales a las
grandes urbes entonces el campo se está
quedando sin mano de obra sin escapan
atrás para las generales de la regla yo
creo que también en canadá está
sucediendo eso yo record
conversé recientemente con una persona
que viene de una zona rural en canadá y
dices que ya no hay jóvenes en esta en
estas zonas rurales tan solo los abuelos
y es difícil porque la economía y no
está funcionando y ahí es donde muchos
inmigrantes de afortunada o
desafortunadamente entran en juego
porque vienen y viven en esas regiones y
trabajan desafortunadamente
afortunada o desafortunado de material
también es cierto que ayer nada menos
que ayer
hace muy pocas horas hubo sectores
empresariales que manifestaron que se
están trayendo inmigrantes que no
responden el perfil que necesita el
mercado laboral también entonces está
que eso es otra discusión por un lado
está el hecho de tener que mantener una
determinada cantidad un determinado
flujo de inmigrantes que llegan al país
pero también creo yo hay que hacer un
ajuste y respecto al perfil de esos
inmigrantes porque hay muchísimos
inmigrantes aquí nuevas para huertas que
tienen muchísima formación que tiene
muchísima experiencia y que no están
pudiendo insertarse en su actividad es
decir de gente totalmente desaprovechada
exactamente no nos queda muchísimo
tiempo así que vamos rapidísimo a leer
algunas cartas
[Música]
así que dije carticas pero son mensaje
ticos mensaje ticos en este caso lo
tengo un tema primicia mundial en canadá
sin planta glándula tiroides en el brazo
y yo el xerez de argentinas dice hola
soy yo el y no tengo glándula tiroides
podré tener un implante nosotros no
sabemos probablemente un médico podría
hablar contigo de la posibilidad o no de
realizar un implante de estas
características ay qué sonido tan raro
tienes algo por ahí tengo un mensaje que
nos hace llegar
eric sobre el tema venta de ciudadanías
que nos dice cómo contactar a los
intermediarios me interesa tengo doble
nacionalidad y desearía vender la
americana bueno yo le diría es que por
empezar cayó en mal lugar si lo que
quiere proponer en un mercado negro de
las ciudadanías y en todo caso ventilar
ese tipo de propuestas no creo que sea
la manera más inteligente de buscar de
dar tranquilidad al contrario
a revelar y no podemos revelar más
porque no tenemos una desaladora de
helio night en ghosts y otro mensaje
pequeño mensaje que dice médico
canadiense dice que la diabetes tipo 2
es curable
avelino masías de león nos dice muy
buena información muchas gracias
sigan con estos reportajes que ayudan a
las personas con este mal a tener un
hálito de esperanza y yo aquí
rápidamente tengo un mensajito sobre el
tema en canadá primer santuario en el
mundo para ballena acidez y delfines en
cautiverio y ligia kaman o comenta y qué
hay del negocio de las pieles de foca la
matanza anual de crías es cruel y feroz
y el gobierno hace caso omiso a la
opinión mundial las especies animales no
son propiedad de nadie son patrimonio de
la humanidad y comentarles simplemente
que canadá tiene políticas muy estrictas
en cuanto al la caza de focas y al no
número de focas que pueden ser casadas
por los indígenas que hacen eso
tradicionalmente desde desde milenios
por parte de la casa comercial también y
que las crías los bebés no pueden ser
casadas igual las imágenes son realmente
pero claro justamente esta semana hice
un reportaje sobre sobre las imágenes
que a veces circulan de forma viral y
que no tienen sustento científico o de
otros sustentos que podría ser el caso
yo lo leí el artículo todo el del oso yo
la foto del pobre oso ese famélico y en
realidad
los expertos dicen que no necesariamente
es muy viejo muriéndose no
necesariamente por el cambio climático
que si los afecta directamente pero no
era necesariamente es al revés en esa
fotografía y en ese vídeo y national
geographic que retomó ese vídeo que
había sido filmado por algunos
conservacionistas canadienses hizo su
mea culpa y le dijo les dijo el ahora
tal vez nos equivocamos
entonces tal vez el oso estaba enfermo
tal vez
era las está por morir entonces bueno
hay siempre interpretación a hacer sobre
los sobre las imágenes
américo al mismo tiempo también
exactamente puede ser entonces todos
estos reportajes y más y muchísimos más
porque hacemos muchos para ustedes
durante toda la semana se encuentran en
nuestro sitio internet quien lo va a
decir triple w
rc y net punto o sea y si a ustedes por
ejemplo entran en uno de los de los
reportajes o actualidades hay
estudiantado para que vean se puede ir a
la barra derecha si no se acuerda por
ejemplo louis dijo de que habló esta
semana y no se acuerdan quieren verlo
pueden ir a navegar por autor juramento
de los autores o por categorías y saben
la categoría en la que se encontraba así
que esta es una información interesante
también muchas gracias leonardo gimeno
luis laborda paloma martínez en los
controles técnicos chantal sansó bar
esto fue todo por canadá en las américas
café hasta la próxima
[Música]